Hi everybody, this is Roman Mars. The following is a new podcast series that the 99% invisible team, led by supervising producer Christopher Johnson, produced with proximity media, in partnership with Warner Brothers. It's a companion to the new film, Judas and the Black Messiah, and it's unlike anything we've ever worked on, and unlike any other movie podcast in scope and ambition. I'm so glad we're making it in conjunction
大家好，我是罗曼·马尔斯。接下来是一个全新的播客系列，由监制克里斯托弗·约翰逊领导的 99% Invisible 团队与 Proximity Media 合作制作，并联合华纳兄弟推出。这是新电影《犹大与黑弥赛亚》的官方配套播客，它与我们以往制作过的任何节目都不同，在规模和雄心上也超越了任何其他的电影播客。我非常高兴能与这样一部极其重要且真正优秀的电影合作。
with such an important and truly excellent film. This is the first in a series of podcasts that I've been cooking up with my friend, the filmmaker Ryan Coopler, who is a huge podcast fan, by the way. It's literally the first thing we ever talked about when we met a couple of years ago. The different podcast series at the Prox and 99 PI teams
这是我与我的朋友、电影制作人瑞安·库格勒一同构思的一系列播客中的第一部。顺便说一句，瑞安本人也是个超级播客迷。这简直是我们几年前见面时聊的第一个话题。Proximity 和 99 PI 团队一直在酝酿不同的播客系列，
have been kicking around, we'll tell stories based on proximity media, film productions, as well as audio first podcast originals. So give this a listen, watch the movie, and go subscribe to the Judas and the Black Messiah podcast and its own feed to hear the rest of the episodes over the next five weeks. And if you all subscribe, we'll get to produce a bunch more stuff together. Trust me, you want that to happen. You are going to flip out for the stuff that proximity has planned. Follow the link in the show notes to subscribe
我们将根据 Proximity Media 的电影作品以及纯音频的原创播客来讲述故事。所以，请收听这个节目，观看这部电影，并去订阅《犹大与黑弥赛亚》播客及其专属订阅源，在未来五周内收听其余的单集。如果你能订阅，我们就能一起制作更多精彩内容。相信我，你一定会希望这发生的。Proximity 策划的内容绝对会让你大开眼界。点击节目简介中的链接进行订阅，
for you listen to episode one right now. Thanks. Hetzup, this episode has some strong language. Here's up eyes open to fifths. Clint y'all know what this is and how we do this. It's chairman Fred Hampton, Jr. the Black Panther Party Cubs. In some sense, in eyes of the state,
现在就去收听第一集吧。谢谢。提醒一下，本集含有粗俗语言。睁大眼睛，握紧拳头。克林特，你们都知道这是什么以及我们是怎么做的。我是黑豹党青年团主席小弗雷德·汉普顿。从某种意义上说，在国家的眼里，
I may be seen as a three-strike offender, one for somebody being African, two for being the son of chairman Fred and the Corps and Jerry, and three for continuing to fight with liberation of my people. I'm honored and humbled to be the international chairman of the Black Panther Party Cubs, the organization that as we say, not walking in its footsteps, but the Panther Paul Steves or the Black Panther Party.
我可能会被视为一个“三振出局”的罪犯：第一，因为我是非洲后裔；第二，因为我是弗雷德主席和阿库阿·安杰里的儿子；第三，因为我继续为解放我的同胞而战斗。我很荣幸也很谦卑能担任黑豹党青年团的国际主席，正如我们所说，这不是追随黑豹党的足迹，而是黑豹党的足迹本身。
Chairman Fred Hampton, Jr. is based in Chicago. As a working activist, he travels almost constantly for protests, rallies, and speaking engagements. In 2012, he was in Northern California, visiting a chapter of the Black Panther Party Cubs. An organization he founded to carry on the legacy of the Black Panther Party. Chairman and the Cubs heard that Nipsey Hussle was performing in Sacramento. We at the concert, we backstage packed house and Nipsey Hussle was backstage. Now, I see him from a distance, So I see the necklace he has on. And at the time, there was a big thing,
小弗雷德·汉普顿常驻芝加哥。作为一名活跃的社会活动家，他几乎马不停蹄地奔波于抗议活动、集会和演讲场合。2012年，他访问了加利福尼亚北部，拜访了黑豹党青年团的一个分部。这是一个由他创立、旨在延续黑豹党遗志的组织。主席和青年团听说尼普西·胡斯将在萨克拉门托演出。我们在演唱会上，后台挤满了人，尼普西·胡斯就在后台。这时，我从远处看到了他，我看到了他戴的项链。当时，这是一种很大的潮流，
a lot of artists in the chain as they were wearing it. Jesus pinned it, Kanye wears so on and so forth. So that was my first thought when I seen it. Man, you might ask like, give him the shaky round this time. So, then I got a little closer. I said, whoa, that's Malcolm X.
很多艺术家都在戴着这种链子。耶稣吊坠，坎耶也戴，诸如此类。所以当我看到它时，我的第一反应是：天哪，你可能会觉得这时候应该去和人握手寒暄。接着，我走近了一些。我说：“哇，那是马尔科姆·X。”
Nipsey's postcard-sized medallion depicted a golden sparkling Malcolm in his classic pose. and I got a little closer, I said, whoa, that's Malcolm X. Nipsy's postcard-sized medallion depicted a golden sparkling Malcolm in his classic pose, index finger pressed to his cheek, contemplating. It's signal to Chairman Jr. that he wasn't talking to a typical rap superstar with typical taste and jewelry. Nipsy Hussle might be a fellow revolutionary.
尼普西明信片大小的挂坠上刻着一个金光闪闪的马尔科姆的经典姿势，食指按在脸颊上，陷入沉思。这向小主席发出信号：他面对的不是一个品味平庸珠宝的典型说唱巨星。尼普西·胡斯可能也是个志同道合的革命者。
And I said, are you familiar with Chairman Fred Hampton? And he said, Chairman Fred Hampton, Jr. What type of man would I be if I didn't know who Chairman Fred Hampton was? Hi, I'm Elvis Mitchell and this is the official podcast of the film, Judas and the Black Messiah. In this series we're looking at the black Messiah at the center of this film, the real story of Fred Hampton. We're going to say it's happening, but I have to have a rock, though, that you can jail or revolution, but you can't jail or revolution. But when I leave, you can know my sins, with the last words on my lips, I am a revolutionary. Chairman Fred Hampton left the Black Panther Party in Illinois until his life was cut short
我说：“你熟悉弗雷德·汉普顿主席吗？”他说：“小弗雷德·汉普顿主席？如果我不知道弗雷德·汉普顿主席是谁，那我算什么人？”嗨，我是埃尔维斯·米切尔，这是电影《犹大与黑弥赛亚》的官方播客。在这个系列中，我们将探讨这部电影核心的黑弥赛亚，即弗雷德·汉普顿的真实故事。我们要说的是，虽然你可以把革命者关进监狱，但你无法把革命关进监狱。但当我离去时，你们会知道我的决心，带着我唇边的最后一句话：我是一个革命者。弗雷德·汉普顿主席领导了伊利诺伊州的黑豹党，直到他的生命在
in 1969. What made Hampton so special that he was annoying to this leader at such a young age and then targeted in a federal assassination? We'll go behind the scenes with the film's creators, including director Shocka King and producer Ryan Cogler, who wrote and directed the 2018 blockbuster, Black Panther. I'll talk to co-stars, Daniel Calloya, a Keith Stanford, and Dominique Fishback,
1969年戛然而止。是什么让汉普顿如此特别，以至于他在如此年轻的时候就成为了一位备受瞩目的领袖，并最终成为联邦暗杀的目标？我们将幕后走访电影的创作者，包括导演沙卡·金和曾编剧并执导2018年票房大片《黑豹》的制片人瑞安·库格勒。我还将与主演丹尼尔·卡卢亚、阿什顿·桑德斯和多米尼克·菲什巴克对话，
also to real panthers who knew Chairman Fred, including his widow, Akua and Jerry, and Chairman Fred Hampton Jr. Around Akua and Jerry, and Chairman Fred Hampton Jr. Around here, we just call him Chairman. He was born three weeks after the assassination and has spent his life protecting his father's legacy. Chairman Jr. was a cultural expert who consulted on Judas and the Black Messiah. He's going to help set the record straight about the Chicago Panthers and Chairman Fred Hampton's senior. In the film, we first see Chairman Seniors' character
还将与认识弗雷德主席的真正的黑豹党人对话，包括他的遗孀阿库阿·安杰里和小弗雷德·汉普顿。在这里，我们都叫他“主席”。他出生于暗杀事件发生三周后，一生都在守护他父亲的遗志。小主席是一位文化专家，曾担任《犹大与黑弥赛亚》的顾问。他将协助还原关于芝加哥黑豹党和老弗雷德·汉普顿主席的历史真相。在电影中，我们第一次看到老主席的角色时，
when he's about 20 years old and moving at full speed. He's leading the Panthers Illinois chapter. He's also building Chicago's original Rainbow Coalition, a political alliance of poor Southern whites, Puerto Ricans, and black youth activists. Chairman Fred Sr. is a force. But in this episode, we're first going to take a step back and look at how Fred Hampton became Chairman Fred. Hampton's parents were from Louisiana.
他大约20岁，正处于全速前进的状态。他领导着黑豹党伊利诺伊州分部。他还在芝加哥建立最初的“彩虹联盟”，这是一个由南方贫困白人、波多黎各人和黑人青年活动家组成的政治联盟。老弗雷德主席是一股不可忽视的力量。但在本集中，我们要先退一步，看看弗雷德·汉普顿是如何成为“弗雷德主席”的。汉普顿的父母来自路易斯安那州。
They moved north into the 1940s, eventually settling in Maywood, on Chicago's west side. Chairman Fred was speaking, but it's coming up, it's growing up. And he said, you know, he said, I came from an OK situation, the well, you know, our situation. And you know, area he grew up in, Maywood. People were for this written class, families, and we were references to Petty Bush, YZ. Fred was born in 1948, the youngest of three children.
他们在20世纪40年代向北迁移，最终定居在芝加哥西郊的梅伍德。弗雷德主席在谈到他的成长经历时说，你知道，他说，我来自一个还可以的环境，我们的情况也还好。你知道，他成长的那个地方，梅伍德。那里的人们为了这个工人阶级家庭而努力，我们属于小资产阶级。弗雷德出生于1948年，是三个孩子中最小的一个。
Even as a boy, he was fiercely protective. He was family and his community. Chairman Jr. tells the story of his father at 11 or 12 years old, leading a protest complete with homemade picket signs. Recognizing that there's a swimming pool where the black children are not able to go swim at, and to see right across with a place
即使在还是个小男孩的时候，他也极其具有保护欲，保护着他的家人和社区。小主席讲述了他父亲在11或12岁时领导了一场抗议活动的故事，甚至还带着自制的纠察标语。当时他发现有一个游泳池，黑人儿童是不能进去游泳的，而就在马德罗斯公园那样的地方，
such as Melrose Park, where the white children will swim pool, and the challenge that across with them places such as Melrose Park, or you know, the White Trident, it was swimming pool. And the challenge that taking cardboard and sticks and making these poses and we demand a swimming pool and going up around the police station and police throwing a tear gas canister out there at them. And him taking a tear gas canister and throwing it back inside the police station.
白人儿童却有游泳池。他拿着硬纸板和木棍制作标语，高呼我们要求拥有游泳池，并走到警察局附近，警察向他们投掷催泪瓦斯罐。而他竟然抓起那个催泪瓦斯罐，又把它扔回了警察局里面。
And even before he was even in school, his brother who was old in him coming home and had been attacked by some white boys at the school. And he took a wagon full of bottles and went over there and he dealt with it. Even in high school, proviso, East, countless cases where he would speak up for others. Fred Hampton went to a school that was surprisingly
甚至在他上学之前，他哥哥比他大，有一次放学回家被学校里的几个白人男孩袭击了。他推着一车满是瓶子的手推车过去，把这事给平息了。甚至在普罗维索东中学的日子里，也有无数次他为他人挺身而出的事例。弗雷德·汉普顿上的学校出人意料地
integrated in the sense of there were a lot of black and white students there, provide the least high school. Shuka King directed, co-wrote, and was a producer on Judas and the Black Messiah. But just because they were going to school together, it didn't mean that they got along and there was a lot of fighting and Fred Hampton, you know, he created an interracial coalition between black and white students to sort of address a lot of the hostility and the fight that was going on.
具有包容性，因为那里有很多黑人和白人学生，那就是普罗维索东中学。沙卡·金是《犹大与黑弥赛亚》的导演、联合编剧兼制片人。但仅仅因为他们在一起上学，并不意味着他们能和平相处，那里有很多冲突。而弗雷德·汉普顿，你知道的，他在黑人和白人学生之间建立了一个跨种族的联盟，以此来应对当时存在的许多敌意和冲突。
It got on the radar of the FBI at a very young age. I believe his phone was tapped when he was 14 years old, just because he was involved in politics incredibly early on. Fred wasn't just involved. In his early teens, he was elected president of the local NAACP youth chapter. As a high school student, he spearheaded a fight to bring in more black teachers. He broke into a meeting between the NAACP and school administrators to address a list of concerns, including the way black students were disciplined. It was clear to everyone around him that young Fred Hampton was a gifted leader.
他在很小的时候就进入了联邦调查局（FBI）的视线。我相信他在14岁时电话就被窃听了，仅仅因为他极早地参与了政治活动。弗雷德可不仅仅是参与其中。在他十几岁出头的时候，他就被选为当地全国有色人种协进会（NAACP）青年分会的会长。作为一名高中生，他带头争取引进更多的黑人教师。他甚至闯入了NAACP与学校管理人员的会议，提出了一系列关切，包括黑人学生受到的纪律处分问题。他身边的每个人都清楚，年轻的弗雷德·汉普顿是一位天赋异禀的领袖。
Think it was Leonard that said that it takes people 20 years of learning ordinary times. They can learn in two years in revolutionary times. People say, well, how was it the FBI be tapping his telephone? When he's 14, they recognize his organizing capabilities. When he's taking the junior NAACP from 7 to 300 members, 7 to have more time period. It was up front to can afford the luxury of procrastination.
我想伦纳德曾说过，普通时代需要人们用20年去学习的东西，他们在革命时代只需两年就能学会。人们会说，为什么FBI会在他14岁时就窃听他的电话？因为他们认出了他的组织能力。当他把青年NAACP的成员从7人发展到300人，仅在很短的一段时间内。这就占据了先机，容不得半点拖延。
["The Legend of the World"] By the time Fred Hampton graduated high school in 1966, there was a real sense of urgency in the air. The Vietnam War was escalating, so two were anti-draft and anti-war protests. The struggles for black empowerment were also intensifying, and Chicago, the black population, had been rising steadily for almost six decades. Nearly one in three Chicagoans was black, and most of them were segregated into neighborhoods
当弗雷德·汉普顿于1966年从高中毕业时，空气中弥漫着一种真正的紧迫感。越南战争正在升级，反征兵和反战抗议活动也是如此。黑人赋权运动的斗争也在加剧，在芝加哥，黑人人口已经连续近六十年稳步增长。几乎每三个芝加哥人中就有一个是黑人，其中大多数人被隔离在城市的南部或西部的社区里。
on the south or west side of the city. Urban renewal, or James Baldwin famously called Negro removal, devastated Chicago's black belt. Slum lords, the police, and city leaders help create and reinforce some of the worst slums in the country. Activist groups emerged to fight this and other anti-poverty anti-racist struggles throughout Chicago. Fred Hampton was coming into his own
城市更新——詹姆斯·鲍德温曾著名地称之为“驱逐黑人”——摧毁了芝加哥的黑人聚居区。贫民窟房东、警察和城市领导人共同制造并巩固了全美最糟糕的一些贫民窟。激进主义团体在芝加哥各地涌现，以对抗这种状况以及其他反贫困、反种族主义的斗争。正是在这种青年主导的激进主义思潮蓬勃发展之际，弗雷德·汉普顿开始崭露头角。
as his youth-driven activist ferment was blooming. All this changed on April 4, 1968. Ladies and gentlemen, I have some very sad news for all of you. Martin Luther King was shot and was killed tonight in Memphis, Dense. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
这一切在1968年4月4日改变了。女士们先生们，我有一个非常不幸的消息要告诉大家。马丁·路德·金今晚在孟菲斯遭枪击身亡。
Yeah. Chicago, Detroit, Boston, New York. These are just a few of the cities in which the Negro language over Dr. King's murder expressed itself in violent destruction. People took to the street. A lot of businesses were burnt. Things changed in terms of atmosphere.
芝加哥、底特律、波士顿、纽约……这些只是黑人因马丁·路德·金遇刺而通过暴力破坏表达愤怒的部分城市。人们走上街头。许多企业被焚毁。气氛彻底改变了。
The political climate became more repressive. Billy Che Brooks grew up in Chicago, and later became Deputy Minister of Education for the Illinois Chapter of the Black Panther Party. After King was killed, Che witnessed a shift among his peers towards more radical activism. People became more assertive in terms of organizing.
政治气候变得愈发高压。比利·切·布鲁克斯在芝加哥长大，后来成为黑豹党伊利诺伊州分部的副教育部长。金遇害后，切见证了同龄人向更激进的激进主义转变的过程。人们在组织方面变得更加坚定。
You go into the height of, you know, anti-war movement or the whole concept of anti-puralism, anti-capitalism, you know, anti-fascism was something that was really enfocalized as a mass movement. That was like the spring and summer of 68. And that was fertile ground for our organization here to Black Panther Party.
你进入了反战运动的高潮，或者反帝国主义、反资本主义、反法西斯主义的整个概念，这些真正作为一个群众运动被集中体现出来。那是68年的春夏之交。这为我们黑豹党这个组织提供了肥沃的土壤。
Bobby Seale and Huey Newton founded the Black Panther Party for self-defense in Oakland, California in 1966. Two years later, the party had expanded to 5,000 members in 49 chapters across the country. Fred Hampton was still in the NAACP when he first encountered the Black Panthers in 1968. The Panthers' national leadership was already talking about the powerful charismatic young leader in Chicago. They would get worried. People would tell, you need to check out this individual. You heard about Fred Hampton,
鲍比·瑟尔和休·牛顿于1966年在加利福尼亚州奥克兰创立了自卫黑豹党。两年后，该党已在全国49个分部拥有5000名成员。弗雷德·汉普顿在1968年首次接触到黑豹党时，仍然是NAACP的成员。黑豹党的全国领导层当时已经在讨论芝加哥这位强大而富有个人魅力的年轻领袖了。他们开始关注他。人们会说，你们得去看看这个人。你听说过弗雷德·汉普顿吗？
you know, servants recognize servants and leaders recognize leaders. In 1968, the party's national leadership reached out to Fred Hampton and asked him to join the Black Panthers. For Fred Hampton, I know for him, specifically, the assassination of Martin Luther King and I think
你知道，同道中人识别同道中人，领袖识别领袖。1968年，黑豹党全国领导层联系了弗雷德·汉普顿，邀请他加入黑豹党。对于弗雷德·汉普顿来说，我知道对他的具体影响而言，马丁·路德·金的遇刺，以及他对无法通过NAACP获得他想要的影响力所产生的某种不满。我的意思是，即使在普罗维索东中学，他领导的事情之一就是争取更好的午餐。
just some of his dissatisfaction with not feeling like he was able to have the time to impact he wanted with the NAACP. I mean, even at Proviso East, one of the things he was leading was the need for there to be better lunch. Fred Hampton, along with another panther named Bobby Rush, and several other party members formed the Illinois chapter. They opened their office in West Chicago in November 1968, and Chairman for Hampton, who had just turned 20 a few months earlier, was quickly becoming one of the party's most
弗雷德·汉普顿与另一位黑豹党人鲍比·拉什以及其他几位党员共同组建了伊利诺伊州分部。他们在1968年11月在西芝加哥开设了办事处，而几个月前刚满20岁的弗雷德·汉普顿主席迅速成为该党最杰出的声音之一。
prominent voices. If everything was put back in the hands of people, that's better for choosing something else. You oughta be. I'm here ever since this audience come on down and help us get back to the children program. Y'all are here coming out and help feed the children in the moment. Ah! It's not surprising that when he heard the Panthers' ideology about like free breakfast programs,
如果一切都交还给人民，那对于选择其他道路会更好。你们应该……自从这个听众来这里帮助我们恢复儿童项目以来，我就一直在这里。欢迎大家来帮忙在这个时刻喂养孩子们。啊！毫不奇怪，当他听到黑豹党关于免费早餐计划之类的意识形态时，
he was like, I'm already thinking in this way. And so it was a natural fit for the way he was already progressing. Yeah, it was the perfect place for him that kind of intersection for him for his, his activist band, but why do you think he made that move into that kind of selflessness because he was on this track to become,
他的反应是：“我本来就已经在这样思考了。”所以这与他当时的发展方向不谋而合。是的，这是对他的完美契合，是他激进主义的交汇点。但你认为是什么促使他走向那种无私奉献的道路的呢？因为他原本完全可以走上
probably part of that thriving, successful Chicago middle class, which drew people to, therefore around the country, because he was on this track to become probably part of that thriving successful Chicago middle class, which drew people to there from around the country. What push him in that direction do you think of activism? Honestly, it really feels like he was kind of born like that. That's the thing that's really crazy. You know, in my conversations with Fred Hampton Jr., he would be like, you have
蓬勃发展、成功的芝加哥中产阶级道路，这吸引着全国各地的人们来到那里。是什么推动他走上了激进主义的方向？老实说，感觉他天生就是这样的人。这才是真正疯狂的地方。你知道，在我和小弗雷德·汉普顿的谈话中，他会说，你必须
to understand that he kind of came here like that. Me and my sister, I was born in a so-called bourgeois community, and I found that even some of the better things are like black people. And I found it with more people stopping than it was he believed. And I made a commitment to myself that I wouldn't keep the stuff in the world. She believes that I made a commitment to myself, that I wouldn't stop doing what I'm doing into all those people, I'm free. She was so, what do you attribute that to? Others have told me, but my mother I recall telling me about the impact
明白他生来就是这样的。我和我姐姐出生在一个所谓的资产阶级社区，我发现即使是黑人能享受到的较好条件，也有很多人在止步不前，而他相信应该做得更多。我向自己承诺，在所有人获得自由之前，我绝不会停下脚步。她相信我向自己做出的承诺，即在所有那些人获得自由之前，我绝不会停止我正在做的事情。那你把这归因于什么呢？其他人告诉我，我母亲曾跟我提起我曾祖父的影响——我也很幸运能在有生之年见到他。作为曾祖父，他带还是孩子的他去路易斯安那州的不同树木旁，告诉他哪些人曾被吊死在哪棵特定的树上，给她讲那些他如何影响了老弗雷德的战争故事。
of my great grandfather, who I was fortunate to, you know, see in my lifetime also, who was his grandfather, taking him as a child around in Louisiana, showing them the different trees and giving them the names of who was hung on what particular trees of her war stories of how he impacted Jimmy Fred.
（注：此段原文存在重复拼接，按原意翻译）
I believe that he related to the Black Panther Party because it's a turn they use, and they say in church, that's your calling. The Black Panther Party, it fit for him. You know, It was natural. You know, some people can say like in relationships, they say, oh, this is this is it. Or it's almost cooking food. They can say, that's it. That's the right season. That's right. That's no more. No, no, no. Cut the stove off. That's connected with it.
我相信他与黑豹党产生共鸣，因为用他们在教堂里的话说，那是你的“召唤”。黑豹党对他来说非常合适。你知道，那是很自然的。你知道，正如人们在形容感情时会说“就是这个”；或者就像烹饪时，你可以说“就是这个，调味刚刚好，不用再加了，关火吧”，这与它有着天然的联结。
Chairman Fred was a Black Panther internally externally. It was in them. And like many other Panther leaders, Chairman Senior was a constant target for law enforcement. In the spring of 69, he was convicted of robbing a good humor truck and handing out free ice cream. His sentence was two to five years. He was released on bail later that summer, just a couple weeks before his 21st birthday. Later, like an hour and a three. Something down inside of the second box, I'm gonna get... ...acting, it's gonna be taken against me and I'm gonna be in the middle of the party, and I got out of the wild, and I'm a prisoner. Some down inside the second box, I'm gonna get... Actually, it's gonna be taken against me and the members of the party
弗雷德主席无论在对内还是对外，都是一个彻头彻尾的黑豹党人。这种精神融入了他的骨血。和其他许多黑豹党领袖一样，老主席一直是执法部门不断针对的目标。69年春天，他因抢劫一辆“好品味”（Good Humor）冰淇淋车并分发免费冰淇淋而被定罪。他的刑期是两年到五年。当年夏天晚些时候他获得保释，就在他21岁生日的几周前。后来，大约一个小时后的三十分钟内，在第二个盒子里面的某个东西，我会……这种行为将被用来反对我和党内的成员，而我竟然不知道自己为什么不害怕。我发现了一种……你发现了吗？我因人民而振奋。我不得不把双手按在地上，当我把双手按在地上时，我听到了一种心跳。那只是一种心跳。太热了……
and I don't know why I'm not scared. I've found a bit of how people... You have? I'm high off the people. I had to put my hands to the ground and when I flip my hands to the ground, I heard a beat. I was just a beat. It's a hot...
太热了……太热了……（注：此段原文有口吃与混乱，保持字面对应）
It's hot... It's a hot... You know, people say that he had charisma. Yeah. I was attracted to him because of his commitment, his willingness to lead by example. He never talked about things that he hadn't done or was not in the process of doing. I love John Fret because the love that not only he showed me, but he showed other comrades, he showed people in the community. And to me that's not charisma, that's commitment. And he often spoke about having that commitment, undying love for the people and all. So I wasn't going to join the group that Bobby Lee Rush was in
你知道，人们说他很有个人魅力。是的，我被他吸引是因为他的承诺，他愿意以身作则的意愿。他从不空谈他没有做过或没有在做的事情。我爱老弗雷德，不仅因为他对我的爱，还因为他对其他同志的爱，他对社区人民的爱。对我和来说，这不仅仅是魅力，这是承诺。他经常谈到要对人民怀有这种承诺、至死不渝的爱。所以，我原本不打算加入鲍比·李·拉什所在的那个组织，
until I met Fred, Jammy Fred, my brother, because that's how simple it was, you know, he just showed that this is who I am, this is what I wanna do, you wanna do a win. So yeah, man, we good. Till this day. Chairman had a magnetism about him, and the Chairman always showed respect. He always showed respect to people.
直到我遇到了弗雷德——老弗雷德，我的兄弟，因为事情就是这么简单。你知道，他只是展现了“这就是我，这就是我想做的，你想一起干吗”。所以，是的，兄弟，我们很好，直到今天。主席身上有一种磁场，而且主席总是表现出尊重。他总是对人表现出尊重。
Stan McKinney was a rank and file member of the Illinois Panthers. He was Bobby Rush's bodyguard. He also worked security for Huey Newton co-founder of the Black Panther Party. I think the vehicle of the party was one thing but having a chairman that was so dynamic and so reachable to all people from all walks of life. I mean, chairman could get out
斯坦·麦金尼是伊利诺伊州黑豹党的一名普通党员。他是鲍比·拉什的保镖。他还曾为黑豹党联合创始人休·牛顿担任安保工作。我认为黑豹党的运作机制是一回事，但拥有一个如此富有活力、能够与各行各业所有人打成一片的主席则是另一回事。我的意思是，主席可以走到
going to the pool halls anywhere he went, you know, he galvanized, mesmerized people. So he had that magnetism that drew you to him and the key thing it was genuine, you could feel that. Even brother, since it's all I want to hit y'all to a new, free breakfast program over on the south side next week, free for the babies. There's a scene early on in Judas in the Black Messiah that really captures this. Chairman Fred played by Daniel Caluia and several other Black Panthers go to a pool hall. Chairman moves easily through the crowd, handing out flyers,
台球厅，无论他走到哪里，你知道的，他能把人们凝聚、迷住。所以他有一种吸引你靠近他的磁场，最关键的是它是真诚的，你能感受到这一点。还有，兄弟们，我想告诉大家一个好消息：下周我们在南区将有一个新的免费早餐计划，专为婴儿们免费提供。在《犹大与黑弥赛亚》片头有一个场景完美地捕捉到了这一点。
promoting the Panthers, smiling. In the North Black Panther Party as a man, they defeat every hunry key in Chicago. The Black Panther Party believes in progression. And what that means? Let me first you have free breaths. Then you have free health care. Then you have free education. Thanks for you know you look up.
由丹尼尔·卡卢亚饰演的弗雷德主席和几位黑豹党人走进了一家台球厅。主席在人群中自如穿梭，发着传单，宣传黑豹党，面带微笑。北方黑豹党作为一个整体，战胜了芝加哥的每一个饥饿儿童。黑豹党信奉进步。这意味着什么？首先是免费早餐。然后是免费医疗。接着是免费教育。然后，你知道的，当你抬头看时，
You don't freeze your mouth, fucking say. That scene is based on the scene I read or heard about him going into a nightclub and telling the DJ to stop the music. And then getting up and talking to people and he spoke for a while, people didn't say, oh, what are you doing? They listened. Then the party went back on.
你不会挨饿，该死。那个场景取材于我读到或听到关于他走进一家夜总会并告诉DJ关掉音乐的真实经历。然后他走上去和大家交谈，他讲了一会儿，人们并没有说：“你在这里干什么？”他们在听。然后音乐重新放了起来。
The fact that he could stop a party and talk about ideas, talk about duties, activities, actions that the Panthers were doing locally and wanting to get people involved and then recruit, essentially recruiting in the middle of a disco. Another feat of the Illinois chapter was its ability to find common ground between Chicago street organizations. They represented in Judas as a single fictional gang called the Crowns. In the film, Chairman Fred Sr. hopes to unite the Crowns and the Black Panthers, so he goes to visit their leader, Steele, who's played by Chris Davis. The great O'Reath talk of the West Side.
他能够打断一场派对，去谈论理念、职责、黑豹党在当地开展的活动，并希望让人们参与进来，本质上是在迪厅里进行招募。伊利诺伊州分部的另一个壮举是他们能够在芝加哥的街头组织之间找到共同点。在电影《犹大与黑弥赛亚》中，他们被塑造成一个名为“王冠帮”（Crowns）的单一虚构帮派。在电影中，老弗雷德主席希望联合“王冠帮”和黑豹党，于是他去拜访了他们的领袖斯蒂尔，该角色由克里斯·达维斯饰演。西区伟大的奥里亚斯的演说。
Your name can ring it out, man. It was your world, brother Steve. So, what can I do for you? Well, I don't know what we can do for each other. You all do some great work mobilizing your brothers on the South Side. We are part of national organization. Dedicated to the liberation for press people everywhere. This nigga got some million dollar words don't they
你的名字真是声名远扬啊。那是你的世界，斯蒂尔兄弟。那么，我能为你做点什么？嗯，我不知道我们能为彼此做些什么。你们在南区动员兄弟们方面做得很棒。我们是一个全国性组织的成员。致力于解放各地受压迫的人民。这个黑鬼挺会说百万美元的大词啊，不是吗？
wasn't alive. It's not just talk brother. Our breakfast program is over 3000 kids a week. Motherfucker, the crowns feed more babies than general meals. Now who you think employees are, they might be some dead-ends. Well, right on, brother, right on. The question is, can you do even more? There's over 5,000 crowns in Chicago,
这不是空谈，兄弟。我们的早餐计划每周为3000多名儿童提供餐食。他妈的，“王冠帮”喂养的婴儿比通用磨坊还多。现在你觉得这些员工是谁，他们可能是些走投无路的人。嗯，说得对，兄弟，说得对。问题是，你们能做得更多吗？芝加哥有5000多名“王冠帮”成员，
between your manpower and the parents political platform. We can heal this whole city. And if we take care of Chicago, she, come on, man. In reality, Chairman and the Panthers work with several organizations, including the Blackstone Rangers and the Black Disciples. You know, the street organizations already had a political basis to them, which is not the way that we've been taught. Gangs, black gangs operate. You know, they've just like awesome niggas.
结合你们的人力资源和黑豹党的政治纲领，我们可以治愈整座城市。如果我们照顾好芝加哥，她——少来这一套，兄弟。现实中，主席和黑豹党与多个组织进行了合作，包括“黑石游骑兵”（Blackstone Rangers）和“黑色门徒”（Black Disciples）。你知道，这些街头组织本身就具有政治基础，这与我们被灌输的观念不同。帮派、黑人帮派的运作方式，你知道的，不只是像一群混混黑鬼那样。
And meanwhile, you know, they got stores, like they're like doing things. So he's got street organizations that are already thinking along these ways that he now is coming along as really trying to organize and really get to him and turn them socialists. And then he's integrating across racial lines in them, say, I'm black. And I hate white people. I'm white, and I hate black people. I'm Latin American, and I hate heel, baby. I'm heel, baby, and I hate hip-hop. So we fight amongst each other.
与此同时，你知道的，他们有商店，他们在做实事。所以他面对的街头组织已经有这方面的思考，而他现在出现，真正试图组织他们，让他们转向社会主义。然后他在他们当中跨越种族界限进行整合，他们说：“我是黑人，我恨白人。我是白人，我恨黑人。我是拉丁美洲人，我恨希尔（俚语），宝贝。我是希尔，我恨嘻哈。”所以我们互相争斗。
When the black battle fighters did up to say that we're going to fight against our parents, we still haven't said we're not going to fight. Reaction every piece. We need another reaction, no out-faw. We're going to fight their reaction, we're all those people who get together, and have an international pull-tang revolution.
当黑豹党人站出来说我们要与我们的压迫者战斗时，我们并没有说我们不打算战斗。对每一个反动派作出反应。我们需要另一种反应，而不是退缩。我们要打击那些反动派，将所有这些人们团结起来，进行一场国际性的无产阶级革命。
Right on the way. And that's being all power to peace. Chairman Fred led the Chicago Panthers as they pushed against the notoriously racist police department. And he encouraged others to do the same. Policemen react the same way from three-fifth and seven magnaves and shotguns that the people do. This one, a reactor same way from 357 magnum and shotguns that the people do, and anybody else. And we know how to ward these frantic fashers off.
正合我意。这就是权力归于人民。弗雷德主席领导芝加哥黑豹党反抗声名狼藉的种族主义警察部门。他鼓励其他人也这样做。警察对 .357马格南手枪和猎枪的反应，和人民是一样的。这一种，对 .357马格南和猎枪的反应和人民以及其他人是一样的。我们知道如何击退这些狂热的法西斯分子。
That we have to defend ourselves because only through this proper example of the self-defense and the proper example of retaliation. And by letting these people know that we move from some basic laws, that anything that goes down on the press people on the part of the oppressor it should be reciprocal and in plain polar-tanned workers' language, it takes two to tango as soon as these motherfuckers go we go. Chicago Panthers also took on the city's leadership, especially Mayor Richard J. Daley. As the king of Chicago's Democratic Party, Mayor Daley was the picture
我们必须捍卫自己，因为只有通过正确的自卫示范和正确的反击示范。并通过让这些人明白，我们超越了一些基本规律，压迫者对受压迫人民所做的一切都应该是对等的——用通俗易懂的无产阶级工人的话说，孤掌难鸣，只要这些混蛋动手，我们就奉陪到底。芝加哥黑豹党还挑战了市领导层，尤其是市长理查德·J·戴利。作为芝加哥民主党之王，戴利市长是政治老板的化身。
of a political boss. His infamous daily machine ruled every aspect of city governance and suppressed black political independence. Daly championed Urban Renewal. He claimed there are no ghettos in Chicago, and he sanctioned a broad use of lethal force during the protests that followed Dr. King's assassination. Shoot to kill any icinus, or anyone with a Molotov cocktail in their hand in Chicago. Shoot to main or cripple, anyone looting, any stores in our city. The Panthers challenge the mayor's reign, often by simply stepping around the conventional party machine and taking their political message straight to the community.
他那声名狼藉的戴利政治机器统治着城市管理的方方面面，并压制了黑人的政治独立性。戴利极力推行城市更新。他声称芝加哥没有贫民窟，并且在马丁·路德·金遇刺后的抗议活动中，他批准了广泛使用致命武力。“格杀勿论任何纵火犯，或任何手里拿着莫洛托夫鸡尾酒瓶在芝加哥的人。枪击并致残或致瘫任何在我们城市商店里抢劫的人。”黑豹党挑战了市长的统治，通常的做法是绕过传统的政党机器，将他们的政治信息直接带给社区。
They were up in the ante. They were crossing the confines of conventional fighting. They were crossing the confines of, you know, this is how you address this, you know, you vote, you talk to this designated spokesperson for your leadership, chairman Fred Case, so he would designated the path of the party. We go on to church. And I'd be like, we go on to church. He'd go and implement the size of party, we go on a church and I've been saying we're going to church, he's going to implement the size of the people. And you know that line in the movie when he's like we take care
他们正在提高赌注。他们正在跨越常规斗争的界限。他们正在跨越诸如“这就是你解决问题的方式，你去投票，你跟为你领导指定的发言人谈话”这种界限，而弗雷德主席不是这样，他会带领黑豹党人去教堂。我会说：“我们要去教堂。”他会去贯彻人民的规模。你知道电影里那句台词吗？当他说我们照顾芝加哥时，
of Chicago, imagine not only is it a big city Chicago but it's the Midwest, it's the connection to everything. So the danger I think in having someone that young and that powerful, he's young too. So he's got years, he has a teen, he's doing a list of the teen, he's got years ahead of him. And he's also starting to get the biggest black middle class in the country. Yes, under his tour. I mean, that's the big thing too,
想象一下，芝加哥不仅是一座大城市，它还是中西部，它是通往一切的枢纽。因此，我认为拥有一个如此年轻、如此强大的人所带来的危险在于，他还很年轻。所以他还有好多年，他正处于十几岁，他在做十几岁时的事，他的未来还有很多年。而且他还在开始建立全美最大的黑人中产阶级。是的，在他的领导下。我的意思是，这也是一件大事，
because there's a young black middle class being educated who we're hearing him too. They're also not just young either, they're old, he's got the older folks, he's got white Catholic priests engaged. He's getting free milk from white business and spending grocery stores. And I shouldn't say he has to say they,
因为有一个年轻的黑人中产阶级正在接受教育，他们也在倾听他的声音。他们不仅年轻，还有年长的人，他还让白人天主教神父参与进来。他从白人企业和杂货店获得免费牛奶。我不该说“他”，而应该说“他们”，
because it's really ill in our chapters, don't it? But he's just, it's the combination of great structure and organization and an incredibly charismatic leader, you know? This represents the international directed in the system, because people all over the world were talking about, man, who are these cats? I'm on the platform or politics, you know what I'm saying? And it's standing up and defending the people.
因为这实际上是伊利诺伊州分部共同完成的，不是吗？但这就是伟大的结构、组织以及一位极其富有个人魅力的领袖的结合，你知道吗？这代表了对体制的国际性直接挑战，因为世界各地的人们都在谈论：“天哪，这些家伙是谁？”我在政治的平台上，你知道我在说什么吗？他们挺身而出保卫人民。
There's not just fighting back for their own personal survival, but it's standing up for the people in a serving the people, providing programs for the people, and I just give them some rhetoric. So we say, we always say the black Panther Party that they can do it, they didn't work to us. We might not be back, I might be in jail, but when I leave you can remember I said, with the last words on my lips, I am a revolutionary and you're going to have to keep on saying that, I am the people, I'm not the people and the people are going to have to stand up against the people. That's what the press is doing all over the world."
这不仅是为了他们个人的生存而反抗，更是为了人民挺身而出，为人民服务，为人民提供项目，而不只是空谈政治修辞。所以我们总是说，黑豹党（即使）做到了这一点，他们没有对我们起作用。我们可能回不来，我可能身陷囹圄，但当我离去时，你们会记得我说过的话，带着我唇边的最后一句话：我是一个革命者，你们必须不断地重复这一点：我是人民，如果不是人民，人民就必须站出来反对人民。这就是压迫者在世界各地所做的事情。”
In response to the black panthers growing popularity in the U.S. and globally, the FBI declared war on the organization. But the Panther Party stood firm. Chairman Fred Hampton was an unapologetic socialist. He was clear right about the mission of the Black Panthers. They were the Vanguard Party, fighting to achieve what Hampton call Utopia, a communist state, and to get there, armed revolutionary struggle. He was able to make revolutionary acts and revolutionary principles very logical,
为了回应黑豹党在美国及全球日益增长的popularity（受欢迎程度），FBI对该组织宣战了。但黑豹党立场坚定。弗雷德·汉普顿是一位毫不妥协的社会主义者。他非常清楚黑豹党的使命。他们是先锋党，为实现汉普顿所称的“乌托邦”（一个共产主义国家）而战，而要达到这一目标，就需要进行武装革命斗争。他能够将革命行动和革命原则讲得非常合乎逻辑，
and he was in a friar like the necessity of violence. He had no fear in terms of talking about the reality of defending yourself against fascism, and speaking about it plainly. Ryan Cougler is one of the producers of Judas and the Black Messiah. He also spoke plainly about not fearing death, because for people to be subjugated, the fear of death has to be preded.
他毫不畏惧暴力之必要性。他在谈论针对法西斯主义进行自卫的现实时毫无畏惧，并且言辞直白。瑞安·库格勒是《犹大与黑弥赛亚》的制片人之一。他也直言不讳地谈到不畏惧死亡，因为要让人民被征服，对死亡的恐惧必须被根除。
You know what I mean? You know, he would say things if you were afraid to die, you dead already. If you ever think about me, then it's the end you're gonna do no remedies, never ask, forget about me. I don't want my theft on your mind you did already. If you listen to that from the lens of an oppressor, that's a very terrifying thing to hear. So I think he made oppressors afraid.
你知道我的意思吗？你知道的，他会说这样的话：“如果你害怕死亡，那你已经死了。”如果你曾经想起我，那就是终点，你将无药可救，永远不要问起，把我忘了吧。我不希望我的死占据你的脑海，你已经死了。如果你从一个压迫者的角度去听这些话，那是相当可怕的一件事。所以我认为他让压迫者感到恐惧。
There's a truth of why they assassinated. He was so effective that he was assassinated by the most powerful government on the planet at that time. So you think about something like that. You know, you think about being, you know, so good at something that the most powerful government in the world is like, how do you have to kill this person? And they do it.
他们暗杀他是有原因的。他太有效率了，以至于被当时地球上最强大的政府所暗杀。所以你想想这样的事情。你知道，想象一下，你优秀到连世界上最强大的政府都在想“你必须得杀了这个人”，然后他们真的这么做了。
And try to snuff out everything about this part. I believe I'm going down no car, Ray. I don't believe I'm going down slipping on no ice. I don't believe I'm going down because I got a bad heart. I believe I'm going down do what was born for. I believe I'm going to die for the people. I believe I will be able to die as a revolutionary in the international revolutionary from the tear struggle.
并且试图抹杀这个党的一切。我相信我不会毫无尊严地倒下，雷。我不相信我会因为踩到冰上滑倒而倒下。我不相信我会因为心脏不好而倒下。我相信我倒下是为了我生来所肩负的使命。我相信我会为人民而死。我相信我能够作为一名革命者、作为阶级斗争中的国际革命者死去。
And I think that struggle is going to come. Why don't you deal for the people? Why don't you struggle for the people? Why don't you die as a people?est trouble for the wildest bad people? The whole purpose of the movies to humanize this individual and these people and the thing is you're trying to humanize someone who is super human You know like no one would believe that if we made a straight-up story about Fred Em you wouldn't believe it He didn't sleep. He changed smoked you drank bottomless cups of coffee He didn't have vulnerability. It smoke, he drank bottomless cups of coffee. He didn't have vulnerability, so they had to kill him. FBI director Jay Edgar Hoover wrote in 1968 that one of the goals of his counterintelligence
而我认为这种斗争即将来临。为什么不为人民去奋斗？为什么不为人民去斗争？为什么不作为人民去死？……（注：原文存在重复，保持对应）电影的全部目的就是将这个人以及这些人进行人性化描绘，问题在于，你试图将一个超越常人的人进行人性化描绘。你知道的，如果制作一部直白的关于弗雷德的电影，没人会相信的。他从不睡觉。他抽烟，他喝酒，一杯接一杯地喝咖啡。他毫无脆弱感，所以他们必须杀了他。FBI局长J·埃德加·霍弗在1968年写道，他的反情报计划（被称为
program, known as Co-Intelpro was to prevent the rise of a Messiah who could unify and electrify the militant black naturalist movement. Nearly two years later, on December 4, 1969, before dawn, more than a dozen law enforcement officers rated Fred Hampton's wash-shakongo apartment. Hampton was shot to death in his bed. He was 21 years old. Black Panther Mark Clark was also killed.
“反情报计划”即 COINTELPRO）的目标之一，就是阻止一个能够统一并点燃激进黑人民族主义运动的“弥赛亚”的崛起。近两年后的1969年12月4日黎明前，一多打执法人员突袭了弗雷德·汉普顿位于西芝加哥的公寓。汉普顿在睡梦中被枪杀。年仅21岁。黑豹党人马克·克拉克也一同遇害。
In the decades since Hampton's death, writers, filmmakers, and playwrights have all approached Chairman Jr. and his mother, Akouwun Jerry, asking for their help or their blessing in telling the senior chairman's story. And for decades, they've declined. So why now? We'll be right back.
在汉普顿去世后的几十年里，作家、电影制作人和剧作家纷纷找到小主席和他的母亲阿库阿·安杰里，请求他们协助或准许讲述老主席的故事。几十年来，他们都拒绝了。那么，为什么是现在？我们马上回来。
This podcast is brought to you by Warner Bros. Pictures, Judas and the Black Messiah. The Golden Globe, Critics' Choice, and Saga Award-nominated film, Now Plane, and theaters and streaming exclusively on HBO Max for 31 Days. It's time the world knows the truth about Chairman Fred Hampton. Watch the film, know his name, share his legacy.
本播客由华纳兄弟影片公司《犹大与黑弥赛亚》为您呈现。这部荣获金球奖、评论家选择奖和演员工会奖提名的电影正在各大影院热映，并在 HBO Max 上独家流媒体播放31天。是时候让全世界知道关于弗雷德·汉普顿主席的真相了。观看这部电影，记住他的名字，传承他的遗志。
Judas and the Black Messiah, welcome back. This is the Judas in the Black Messiah official podcast. I'm Elvis Mitchell. Ryan Cugler and his wife and producing partner Zinzi premiered his directorial debut through Fail Station at the 2013 Sundance Film Festival. That's where they met Shaka King. Trap by a blizzard, they all had dinner together. They talked and bonded. And we know we've been tight since. So, you know, Shaka and I had, in Zenzi, we all had a chance to work together.
《犹大与黑弥赛亚》，欢迎回来。这里是《犹大与黑弥赛亚》官方播客。我是埃尔维斯·米切尔。瑞安·库格勒和他的妻子兼制片伙伴辛兹（Zinzi）在2013年圣丹斯电影节上首映了他的导演处女作《弗鲁特维尔车站》。也就是在那里，他们遇到了沙卡·金。由于暴风雪受困，他们一起共进晚餐。他们交谈并建立了深厚的联系。我们知道从那以后我们就一直很紧密。所以，你知道的，沙卡和我，还有辛兹，我们都有机会一起合作。
We got close to this family and stuff. And it became kind of a ritual. Like, whenever we were in New York, we would stop by his house. And checking on his mom and dad, you know, he'd dinner. In 2017, Ryan and Zenzie took a break from their film, Black Panther, and went to visit Shaka. He told the couple about a script he was working on. It was based on an idea that the comic duo,
我们和这个家庭关系变得很近，这成了一种仪式。就像每当我们去纽约，都会顺便去他家，看望他的父母，你知道的，他会做晚饭。2017年，瑞安和津齐暂停了他们电影《黑豹》的工作，去拜访了沙卡。他向这对夫妇讲述了他正在创作的一个剧本。这个剧本基于一个喜剧双人组合的想法，
the Lucas Brothers, had originally brought to Shaka. The story of Chiranford Hampton's assassination told from the perspective of William O'Neill, the car thief who infiltrated the Illinois chapter and helped the FBI plan Hampton's murder. Ryan and Zinsie loved the idea, and once they finished with Black Panther, they came aboard as producers. I know we got into development, and through that process, Shocka was like, look, if we're gonna do this, we have to meet with Chairman's family.
卢卡斯兄弟最初带给沙卡的。切兰福德·汉普顿遇刺的故事，是通过威廉·奥尼尔的视角讲述的，他是一个潜入伊利诺伊州分部并协助联邦调查局策划汉普顿谋杀案的汽车窃贼。瑞安和津齐非常喜欢这个想法，一旦他们完成了《黑豹》的工作，他们就作为制片人加入了进来。我知道我们进入了开发阶段，在这个过程中，沙卡说，听着，如果我们要做这件事，我们必须和主席的家人见面。
You know, we can't make this without the blessing of his family. So Ryan, Zinzi, Shaka, and producer Charles came all went to Chicago and tried to do with other filmmakers that failed to pull off a decade. They met with Chairman Fred Jr. who now lives at the Hampton House, his father's childhood home. And we sat down, you know, let it know who wanted to make the film.
你知道，没有他家人的祝福，我们是拍不成这部电影的。所以瑞安、津齐、沙卡和制片人查尔斯都去了芝加哥，试图完成其他电影制片人十年都没能做到的事。他们见到了小弗雷德·汉普顿主席，他现在住在汉普顿之家的他父亲的童年故居里。我们坐下来，你知道的，让他们知道谁想拍这部电影。
It was really like intimidating. He had a couple of former Panthers there who knew his father, you know, that it not, we wanted to make the film, it was really like intimidating. He had a couple of former Panthers there who knew his father, you know. This was the first of many negotiations with Ampens family. They were skeptical. It became Ryan's job to do most of the convincing. From the beginning, he and Fred Jr. had formed a bond. So, Ryan made several trips to Chairman's Place in West Chicago. I got thinking about how shocked I say he didn't want to do it without him. And we didn't want the experience to be in Validate, man. Like if somebody was to watch the film, and to find out the family had condemned it for a reason I was valid.
这真的很吓人。他在那里有几个认识他父亲的前黑豹党成员，你知道的，这不仅是为了让他们知道我们想拍电影，真的就像一种恐吓。他在那里有几个认识他父亲的前黑豹党成员，你知道的。这是与汉普顿家族多次谈判中的第一次。他们持怀疑态度。说服他们的工作大部分落在了瑞安身上。从一开始，他和由于小弗雷德就建立了一种纽带。所以，瑞安多次前往主席在西芝加哥的住所。我在想沙卡怎么会说没有他就不想拍。我们也不希望这段经历变得毫无价值，伙计。就像如果有人看了这部电影，发现家人因为一个合理的理由而谴责它。
So they kept negotiating. Fred Jr. looked at scripts. He talked to the filmmakers about their vision. And he still was like, nah, it was several sticking points that he was like, Fred Jr. looked at scripts. He talked to the filmmakers about their vision. For about a year and a half, it went like this. Fred Jr. several former Panthers and his mother Akua and Jerry, or Mama Akua, pushing back on the film's title, or how the Panthers were dressed, or how much the Panthers smoked. At one point early in the process, Chairman Fred Tol Ryan,
所以他们继续谈判。小弗雷德看了剧本。他与电影制片人探讨了他们的愿景。但他仍然觉得，不行，还有几个症结让他觉得，小弗雷德看了剧本。他与电影制片人探讨了他们的愿景。大约一年半的时间里，情况一直如此。小弗雷德、几个前黑豹党成员以及他的母亲阿库亚和杰里，或者阿库亚妈妈，对电影的片名、黑豹党的穿着，或者黑豹党抽烟的多少提出异议。在拍摄早期的某个时候，弗雷德主席告诉瑞安，
that they wanted to have a sit down with Daniel Caluia and Dominic Fishback, the actors who be playing his father and mother, Shaka King and producer Charles King came too. The meeting was at the Hampton House. Everyone gathered around a big table with a black and blue Pan Panther symbol in the center. It was long, I mean, we would run a table for like seven hours. Dominique and Daniel were questioned well into the night.
他们想和丹尼尔·卡卢亚和多米尼克·菲什巴克坐下来谈谈，这两位演员将分别饰演他的父亲和母亲，沙卡·金和制片人查尔斯·金也来了。会议在汉普顿之家的举行。大家围坐在一张大桌子旁，正中间是一个黑蓝相间的黑豹标志。时间很长，我是说，我们在桌子旁坐了大约七个小时。多米尼克和丹尼尔在深夜还在接受盘问。
Jim and said, I want to go around this table and know why every single one of you want to do this movie. And he's, I'm gonna start with you. And he said, it's a damn year and I was like, oh, it loves. He was just kind of speaking to us about what's our intentions for telling the story and what do we stand for. Daniel remembers a night well. It was just Chairman and Mama Kuhl just asking questions that really go to the core of the
吉姆说，我想绕着这张桌子转一圈，知道为什么你们每个人都想拍这部电影。他说，我要从你开始。他说，这该死的一年，我当时想，哦，天哪。他只是在跟我们谈论我们讲这个故事的意图是什么，我们代表什么。丹尼尔对那个夜晚记忆犹新。当时只有主席和阿库亚妈妈在问一些真正切中核心的问题，
way we do what we do. And then at the end, Chairman was like, y'all, I'm gonna take you to a hood, you pick one. X for someone to Google, where's neighborhood in Chicago? Cause it's arbitrary with how the town's gonna be kinda hot. And from my recollection, I was like, yo, you told me, you told me where I need to go.
我们做事的雷厉风行。然后在最后，主席说，各位，我要带你们去一个社区，你们选一个。让某人在谷歌上搜索，芝加哥哪个是社区？因为这个镇的局势怎么说都会有点紧张。根据我的回忆，我说，哟，你告诉我，你告诉我我需要去哪里。
And he was like, yeah, if you're gonna, if you're gonna pay the Chairman, I need to know what you're made of and I was like, yeah cool. I respect that, you know Someone pulled up the Weshikha Goneva would call K-town where just a couple days earlier 11 people were shot and two were killed and it was late It was a past midnight and I said okay. Let's go Let's go right there. We're going to continue this meeting right there. Chairman Daniel, Dominique and Charles King all drove to K-Down. Chairman showed them some sidewalk memorials he said had been defaced by the police. And for me how I, I took that in,
他说，对，如果你要，如果你要扮演主席，我需要知道你有什么斤两，我当时想，好的，酷。我尊重这一点，你知道的。有人查出了西芝加哥的一个地方，被称为K镇，就在几天前，那里有11人遭枪击，2人死亡，当时很晚了，已经过半夜了，我说，好吧。我们走吧。我们就去那里。我们要把会议就在那里继续开下去。主席、丹尼尔、多米尼克和查尔斯·金都开车去了K镇。主席给他们看了一些路边的纪念碑，他说这些纪念碑被警察破坏了。而对我来说，我是怎么接受这一点的，
I think Chairman was looking at me, seeing how I was, I think at that moment something shifted. But for me was like, I understood understood I don't have fear in that sense because I understand the gravity of what I'm stepping into and the gravity of what that means to chairman and it's the least I can do how I saw it. I'm from the real world, I'm not from the industry and I understand the certain things you need to go through for someone to see what you're about and feel that you are going to carry a man that means so much to them. Juman Fred and Mamma Kuh had tested Daniel and Dominik's intentions and their metal and the family was impressed but the negotiations between the family and the film makers weren't over just yet. In our next episode, producer Ryan Kugler and Chairman Fred Hampton
我想主席当时在看着我，看我是什么样的，我想在那一刻有什么东西改变了。但对我的感觉是，我明白了，从某种意义上说我并不害怕，因为我理解我所涉足的事情的分量，以及这对主席意味着什么，这是我能做的最起码的事情，我是这么看的。我来自现实世界，我不是这个行业的人，我明白你需要经历某些事情，才能让别人看到你是谁，并感觉到你将承载一个对他们如此重要的人。弗雷德主席和阿库亚妈妈测试了丹尼尔和多米尼克的意图和他们的骨气，家人印象深刻，但家人与电影制片人之间的谈判还没有完全结束。在我们的下一集里，制片人瑞安·库格尔和小弗雷德·汉普顿主席
Jr. talk about some of those sticking points early in production, and how their friendship helped keep Chairman from just walking away. And I'll talk to Mother Akua, Chairman's senior's widow, about how they met and seeing this story brought to life in this film. This podcast is a production of 99% Invisible, proximity media, and Warner Brothers. The series is written by Christopher Johnson, our supervising producer. When the Mars is our editor, our senior producer is Delaney Hall. Avie Madan is our associate producer, special thanks also to producer Emmett Fitzgerald. Our musical is composed by Sean Riel. Graham Haysha is our fact-checker.
谈论了制作初期的其中一些症结，以及他们的友谊如何帮助主席没有直接一走了之。我还将与主席高级的遗孀阿库亚妈妈讨论他们是如何相遇的，以及看到这个故事在这部电影中生动呈现的感受。本播客由99% Invisible、Proximity Media和华纳兄弟联合制作。本系列由我们的主管制片人克里斯托弗·约翰逊编剧。温·马尔斯是我们的编辑，高级制片人是德兰尼·霍尔。阿维·马丹是我们的副制片人，特别感谢制片人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。我们的音乐由肖恩·里尔创作。格雷姆·海沙是我们的事实核查员。
Bryce and Barnes is our mixed engineer. Special thanks to Laila Willes, our sync producer in Chicago. Some of the audio in this episode and in our trailers from the film and the trailer for The Murder of Fred Hampton, which come to us courtesy of the Chicago Film Archives. Footage from Fred Hampton, Black Panthers in Chicago, is a copyrighted video freak courtesy of video data bank at the School of the Art Institute of Chicago. Thanks also to CBS News and the AP Archive for their footage. I'm your host, Elvis Mitchell. See you next time. Radio TV. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
布莱斯·巴恩斯是我们的混音师。特别感谢我们在芝加哥的同步制片人莱拉·威利斯。本集中的部分音频以及我们预告片中的音频来自电影和《谋杀弗雷德·汉普顿》的预告片，这些音频由芝加哥电影档案馆提供。来自弗雷德·汉普顿、芝加哥黑豹党的素材是受版权保护的视频，由芝加哥艺术学院学校的视频数据银行友情提供。同样感谢CBS新闻和AP档案提供他们的素材。我是你们的主持人埃尔维斯·米歇尔。下次见。广播电视。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。